hohe steuern neueste technologien und
eine ordentliche portion psychologie das
alles steckt findet den preisen für
vegane pflanzen krings sebastian liege
erfährt in schweden wie die trendgetränk
produziert werden und zeigt euch wie ihr
sie zu hause günstig selber herstellen
könnt zur herstellung pflanzlicher milch
alternativen braucht es sagte körner
oder nässe und eine maschine im xxl
format für meine barista milch
alternativen habe ich hier eine mixa
pyramide mit 12 ps die mixa sind der
schlüssel zur herstellung von
pflanzlichen drinks nur durch sie wird
allerdings zutaten eine art acht
verschiedene milch alternativen belege
herstellen
dazu hatte die nüsse und kerne mehrere
stunden im wasser eingelegt
wir fangen an mit dem man bilden für ein
mieter soja von den teuren grundzutaten
nimmt sebastian nur ganz wenig
das ist bei der busecker walbecker mehr
drauf man kann da mir jetzt wird es
richtig exotisch hanfsamen und zu guter
letzt preis der günstigste rohstoff von
allen die hier auf dem tisch stehen
insgesamt macht die menge der nüsse und
körner nur wenige prozent der rezeptur
aus
der hauptanteil ist wasser genau 1 liter
damit bleibt der reine warenwert enorm
günstig obwohl lege alle zutaten im
supermarkt eingekauft hat die kosten
liter liegen im cent bereich
[Musik]
auch bei den produkten im handel ist von
der hauptzutat nur ein geringer
prozentsatz im getränk woher kommt dann
der hohe preis
die zubereitung der kuh freien milch ist
zumindest nicht sehr aufwendig auf
knopfdruck acht verschiedene seiten und
nüsse melken mixa power marsch damit aus
wasser und müssen
dann etwas milchiges entsteht werden die
zutaten iv 12 häckselt und vermengt der
milch ersatz ist schon fertig aber zum
aufschreiben reicht noch nicht
am beispiel des hofer drinks lüftet läge
das geheimnis hinter dem schaum erstmal
und filtert er die letzten partikel
heraus genießbaren wäre der hafer drin
jetzt schon
doch fürs aufschreiben fehlen noch
zugaben
auch hier nicht teure regel greift zu
bewerten industrie mitteln ein bisschen
gaga gehen für die bindung damit auch
der gleiche schmelz entsteht wie bei
einer kuhmilch cara gen stammt aus
rotalgen und wird häufig als denn hier
oder verdickungsmittel benutzt jetzt
noch so ja legitim
das pulver muss rein damit läge es kunst
milch mehr fett aufnimmt echte kuh milch
hat natürlich fed unserer hafer milch so
gut wie gar nicht deswegen müssen wir
ein wenig öl hinzufügen um auch dem
entsprechen die stabilität in unserem
schaum hinzubekommen
sebastian greift zusammen
[Musik]
und fertig ist unser barista mich
alternative einfach schnell und aus
günstigen zutaten hergestellt
bevor das ergebnis kann sich sehen
lassen
der hafer drink lässt sich perfekt
aufschäumen zusammengerechnet beläuft
sich sebastians wareneinsatz für die
barista edition auf gerade mal 40 cent
aber warum sind die drinks im handel
dann so teuer in unserer auswahl kosten
alle über zwei euro pro liter das will
sebastian bei einem der größten hafer
drink hersteller weltweit erfahren
dafür fährt er nach schweden gut
gesichert werden hier die hafer drinks
der firma oakley hergestellt seit knapp
einem jahr gibt es die auch in deutschen
supermärkten
zusammen mit sebastian trifft auch eine
neue ladung haferbeck
chv angehört
jeden tag kommt ein lkw mit dem rohstoff
an
so viele hafer will japan geliefert
in jedem rio sind 50 tonnen hk unsere
tägliche umschlag der markt wächst so
schnell dass bald noch mehr werden
fakt ist wer soviel hafer einkauft
erhält ordentlichen mengenrabatt und
zeit weit weniger für das getreide als
sebastian im supermarkt den genauen
einkaufspreis will die firma aber nicht
verraten
rein in die häuser fabrik 8000 liter
packs laufen hier pro stunde vom band
verkaufsschlager ist der teure barista
drink für über 2 euro
doch was sagt die firma dazu dass
sebastian selbst gemachte hab ich ihn
nur 40 cent pro liter gekostet hat bin
ich sicher sie haben einen tollen körper
drink gemerkt aber ohne unsere
technologien erreicht er einfach ist das
gleiche
verglichen mit milch sind pflanzen
brings noch nischenprodukte
fabrikanlagen und verfahren dafür zu
entwickeln kostet geld das muss der
verkaufspreis wieder einspielen
außerdem gibt es faktoren die in
sebastians werkstatt bilanz fehlten
amtliche hygienestandards etwa oder
verpackung und transport
doch die gelten auch für kuhmilch wie
erklärt die firma oakley den immensen
preisunterschied gibt es keinerlei
subventionen und dann das deutsche
steuersystem getränke mit 19 prozent
versteuert
für milch das macht einen großen
unterschied
nachteil durch subventionen
nach unseren recherchen bezuschusst die
eu inzwischen nicht mehr die milch
sondern landwirte allgemein auch der
hafa bauer erhält also für jeden hektar
ackerland geld wieder milchbauer für
seine weiden doch tatsächlich zahlen wir
auf milch mit sieben prozent viel
weniger mehrwertsteuer als die 19
prozent beim hafer drink und auch ein
psychologischer faktor schlägt zu buche
viele verbraucher ist milch etwas nicht
so gut sie wollen wir auf etwas anderes
zurückgreifen dafür sind sie bereit
tiefer in die tasche zu greifen
und auch hier bestimmt natürlich die
nachfrage den preis und die verbraucher
bezahlen gerne mehr vip faktor und
cleveres marketing stehen also auch im
hohen preisen
ärgerlich für alle die auf milch
alternativen angewiesen sind die
menschen mit laktoseintoleranz
das sind schätzungsweise 15 prozent der
deutschen und nicht nur für die drinks
müssen kunden tief in die tasche greifen
auch andere milch ersatzprodukte sind
deutlich teurer als das original von der
kuh in unserer stichprobe kosten
pflanzliche joghurt ersatzprodukte im
schnitt 35 prozent mehr
frischkäse alternativen 37% und seine
alternativen sind 20 cent teurer als
milch haltige produkte
fazit die industrie weiß wie viel kunden
bereit sind zu zahlen und nutzt diese
bereitschaft gerne aus unabhängig vom
warenwert was mögt ihr lieber im café
harfe milch oder kuhmilch sagt es uns in
den kommentaren und wo es die besten
lebensmittel gibt und was wirklich drin
steckt zeigen wir euch auf unserem kanal
zdf besser esser